ya vraiment un refus d'auto critique de
la part de la classe politique on le
voit d'ailleurs ils ne parlent que de
gadgets le vote à distance le vote par
correspondance la majorité à 16 ans
trouver des façons de faire le vote
électronique etc c'est pas ça qui va
faire bouger les gens surtout le vrai
qu'à 16 ans quand on vois pas je vous
interromps quand on voit que les jeunes
n'ont pas voté à 80 7 % aux régionales
18 34 ans on imagine que légende c'est
vraiment voter encore plus pour faire
vraiment et le le vote fin je vous
laisse le continuer maintenant donc donc
c'est pas parce qu'on va avoir des
gadgets techniques ou des façons de
voter plus facile le vote dans les ehpad
on en parlait la semaine dernière dans
le groupe korian qu'on va pousser les
gens à voter non ce qu'il faut c'est les
intéressés à la chose publique eux aussi
de faire comprendre ce devoir citoyen
qu'est le vote parce que le lâcher ces
lâches et aussi le fait de d'accepter de
faire partie de cette communauté alors
on peut avoir des grands débats sur la
laïcité sur l'école sur l'identité
française si on ne vote pas alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait dans ce pays il ya une
vraie question là dessus donc je pense
qu'à une éducation civique et qui est au
plus proche des gens c'est à dire au
niveau local qui est important quand on
voit les régionales et municipales c'est
inquiétant de voir qu'ils aient si peu
de personnes qui se déplacent et puis à
la question de la légitimité ensuite de
ces gens qui sortent des urnes avec si
peu de votants on le voit à l'assemblée
nationale regardez qui sont les gens qui
sont censés être des élus représentants
de la nation ils ne représentent rien et
en plus vous avez le problème en france
que si vous êtes ouvriers salariés
employés vous ne pouvez pas ou c'est
très difficile vous de vous présenter un
mandat électif vous pouvez le faire
quand vous êtes en profession libérale
quand vous êtes issus des grands corps
d'état ou fonctionnaires
mais si vous êtes salarié essayez de
vous présenter un mandat vous allez voir
si vous allez retrouver votre emploi si
vous perdez